you're a history maker man like first
black artists to debut at number one is
that like what did you do when you found
out the news I looked in the mirror like
the rumors are true I am black now man I
just I was super thankful you know when
I found out what number one you know
kind of fell to my knees and you don't
thank God and to it up a little bit and
then something else hit me is like
alright how can I change this narrative
you know how can I make this a normal
thing so to where in two to three years
from now being black isn't a thing you
know because in every other genre it's
not a thing mm-hmm and I'm like how can
i for myself - Kane - Darius - Mickey
guiding the Tony Jackson you know Aaron
vane it's like so many other people how
can we become more mainstream to where
when you see a black country artist
there's no more history to be made as a
first black artist it's just you're just
a country artist doing something you
know where it's not surprising yeah man
it's just and that's nuts and that's
kind of how I kind of it's kind of where
my head turn that doesn't find out oh
yeah I think we're in a place in you
know pop culture in general we want to
celebrate everyone's gift mm-hmm wants
to all great diversity anybody want to
look at it like what you're describing
for sure like where it's not just
special because you are of whatever yeah
yeah but why do you think it is that in
this particular genre but kind of still
in that land we're still that way um you
know I feel like representation is
important mm-hmm as far as when you see
when you're chasing a career no matter
what your career is to be able to look
at it and see someone that looks like
you and honestly you know in the u.s.
until you know as a young kid were told
you to be present he could be President
but until Obama became president of the
u.s. it was hard for a black kid to see
that but I think the mindset should be
shifted to where if you don't see
representation you step out and you
become that representation I feel like a
lot of times if people don't see someone
that looks like them instead of still
having the courage to step out and do it
they kind of venture off and do
something else but I think now we'll
find a place where you know it's cool to
be who you are
you know individuality is something that
you know society's leaning leaning
towards as far as the cool thing to do
so when you find out who you are as a
person you're no longer afraid and you
have the confidence to chase whatever
dream it is that that all you want right
because you want someone to be able to
just go after what I they want over
source of what came before them Yeah
right
definitely yeah how long did you know
that this was the path for you when did
you think to yourself you know what I'm
gonna be a musician this is how I'm
gonna leave my life when I realized I
sucked at everything else in life ya
know then I was a kid man I grew up
playing drums in church and then I I
played drums started playing piano
started singing in band I played the
trumpet so it was like music was kind of
only like all I did for so long and then
I got into musical theater and that's
why I fell in love with the stage and
being able to when I would play
different characters I was like man I
can you can become a different character
in each song and then you can act it out
through the song on stage and grab the
entertainment aspect of performing other
than just singing yeah and that's why I
fell in love with it man the bug bit me
and ever since I was a kid there's
nothing else I've ever wanted to do now
I knew you know one day well after I get
the music happened I'd want to get into
TV and like write a book and all the
other stuff but music was definitely the
platform growing up with you among a
group of people like a group of friends
that were all into the same thing or
were you like you're the guy that likes
music this is the dude that does music
yeah you know my little friends play
sports whatever so we um like in my
neighborhood we had one friend they
played the play football
one guy was in the leg just like just in
the hunting and stuff like that and I
did the music and like we all you know
did the hunting stuff we all play sports
but I was the only one that really kind
of like just started dabbling into the
to the music thing because like we
singing sure it's like my mom sings and
my sister sings my dad sings but it
doesn't sound good you know and best job
what did you know that was special
ma'am I didn't for a long time I just
knew I was headed to a write and I had
that melody in the first line of the
course in my head
when you smile see so I seen Down Goes
Down
telephone it was like stuck in my head
and I couldn't get it out I don't know
what this is so I get to the right and
we're writing with three guys today
actually my buddy JP who I wrote best
eye with and Josh I wrote best shot with
and also our buddy
Jason there's all J's in the room which
is weird um so we're writing this other
song as a y'all got this melody let me
what you think so we're I throw it out
there and the one writer Jason was like
man I'm not quite sure but y'all can
come back on your own and y'all can
finish it so we wrote some other song
that day that I don't even remember it
the me JP and Josh came back I was like
fellas I can't get smelly out of my head
so we wrote the chorus then we sat back
and was like whoa man all right so we
started digging into the verse and then
we left it alone with like a month
that's like fellas we need to go back
and like rework this new person don't
like the first was that course I'm
telling you is there and then the track
at first was like up-tempo was like Fall
Out Boy Meets Florida Georgia line like
it was big guitar I was like yeah this
is not gonna work and and play Bluebird
Cafe and played acoustic for the first
time and then while I'm singing it the
song's hitting me I'm like wow this is
like something cool you know like I was
like and then people came with me
afterwards talking about yeah they like
the songs with that best shot song they
said they connected with us I think we
might have something here so then we
weren't introduced it and we kept it
kept it out back you know so like the
lyric and the vocal could kind of really
you know take take front and center and
like kind of keep the focus on that yes
you